PAST MISTAKES.
BRET.
>> Bret: BENJAMIN HALL IN
LONDON.
THANK YOU.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
OUTLINING THE TERMS OF A
PROPOSED NEW NUCLEAR DEAL WITH
IRAN.
AMERICA'S TOP TO THEM THAT IS
THREATENING WHAT HE CALLS THE
STRONGEST SANCTIONS IN HISTORY
IF IRAN DOES NOT COMPLY.
IRAN IS PREDICTABLY DISMISSIVE.
RICH EDSON HAS SPECIFICS FROM
THE STATE DEPARTMENT TONIGHT.
>> THE UNITED STATES WILL
IMPLEMENT AN AGGRESSIVE CAMPAIGN
TO ECONOMICALLY ISOLATE AND
PUNISH IRAN.
>> THESE WILL END UP BEING THE
STRONGEST SANCTIONS IN HISTORY
WHEN WE ARE COMPLETE.
>> BORROWING A TACTIC AND EVEN A
NAME FROM THE ADMINISTRATION'S
NORTH KOREA POLICY, SECRETARY OF
STATE MIKE POMPEO PROMISES AND
HISTORIC PRESSURE CAMPAIGN
AGAINST IRAN.
STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS SAY
THEY WILL WORK WITH ALLIES TO
CREATE A GLOBAL COALITION TO
COUNTER IRAN.
SECRETARY POMPEO ALSO WARNED
COMPANIES FROM ALLIED COUNTRIES
CONDUCTING BUSINESS WITH IRAN
THAT THE UNITED STATES WOULD
PENALIZE THEM IF THEY CONTINUED
WORKING WITH IRAN.
ALL PART OF WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION SAYS IS A ROBUST
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS IRAN'S
BEHAVIOR BEYOND NUCLEAR
ACTIVITY.
>> WE WILL TRACK DOWN IRANIAN
OPERATIVES AND THEIR HEZBOLLAH
PROXIES OPERATING AROUND THE
WORLD AND WE WILL CRUSH THEM.
IRAN WILL NEVER AGAIN HAVE
CARTE BLANCHE TO DOMINATE THE
MIDDLE EAST.
>> POMPEO LISTED U.S. DEMANDS.
IRAN MUST ABANDON ITS NUCLEAR
WORK IN PERPETUITY.
PROVIDE INTERNATIONAL INSPECTORS
UNQUALIFIED ACCESS.
HALT ITS BALLISTIC MISSILE
PROGRAM.
RELEASE DETAINED AMERICANS.
AND END SUPPORT FOR MIDDLE EAST
MILITANT GROUPS.
IN EXCHANGE, THE SECRETARY SAYS
THE U.S. WOULD LIVE SANCTIONS
AND WELCOME IRAN'S RETURN TO THE
GLOBAL ECONOMY.
IN RESPONSE, IRAN'S FOREIGN
MINISTER TWEETED "U.S. DIPLOMACY
SHAM IS MERELY A REGRESSION TO
OLD HABITS.
IMPRISONED BY DELUSIONS AND
FAILED POLICIES DICTATED BY
CORRUPT SPECIAL INTEREST.
IT REPEATS THE SAME WRONG
CHOICES AND WILL THUS REAP THE
SAME ILL REWARDS."
BRITISH FOREIGN SECRETARY BORIS
JOHNSON SPEAKING JUST AHEAD OF
AGREEMENT ADDRESSING ALL OF
IRAN'S AGGRESSIVE BEHAVIOR WON'T
BE VERY EASY TO ACHIEVE IN A